hello and welcome to the new world
review source for everything anime and
manga and today we are back in the
desolate cursey land of jujutsukaisen in
order to examine a certain uge todori a
man boy who has become one of the more
intriguing shonen protagonist in recent
times and there's a lot to know about
him that is not necessarily conveyed
through the series itself so our purpose
here today is to present 10 glorious
itadore related fun facts that you did
not know and if you did i don't care
because they're still gonna be fun i
also want to point out at the beginning
of this video that this is not going to
be some sort of click baity you know cbr
style list i mean for example in their
article of the top 10 things that you
did not know about yuji they featured
number 10. he's strong number four he's
smart and number two he's popular so we
won't be doing any of that garbage here
and honestly that writer should be
ashamed but for you to avoid the curse
of shame make sure to subscribe to the
new world review which will result in
consistent injections of jujutsuki's and
culture administered straight into your
youtube feed so let's actually begin
with a rather substantive thing at
number 10 about yuji which is that gege
akitami actually has quite a bit of
trouble writing him this was revealed in
yuji's q a section in the jujutsu kaisen
fanbook and akatami themselves has
claimed that they aren't quite sure why
yuji is a bit of a struggle however
akhitami is committed to figuring this
out and to stop quote being bad with
yuji's character which i would say is a
very classic akutami apology statement
at this point i have read a ton of
interviews with akutami and they have a
particularly humble mindset when it
comes to their work always concerned
that something isn't good enough and
even apologizing when they were forced
to take a hiatus for health reasons in
any case i can also see where akutami is
coming from because many main
protagonists are quite difficult
especially with what's being set up in
judas kaisen and there's even been some
evidence to suggest that akutami didn't
put an extensive amount of thought into
yuji when creating him as when asked
about his previous renown as the tiger
of west junior high akutami admitted
that they didn't consider why that
epithet was given but in the end yuji is
the primary anchor of the series and as
an author i imagine that's why akutami
is so hyper focused and harsh on
themselves when it comes to yuji
specifically although i should say that
i for one think he's pretty damn
compelling this does take us to yuji fun
fact number the second however and anime
watches may be somewhat shocked to learn
this but yuji was not the original
protagonist of jujutsu kaiser in fact in
a rather trippy sentence jujitsukai sen
itself is not even the original jujutsu
kaisen the series itself actually began
as a four chapter mini manga which was
helmed by protagonist yuta okotsu and
uta and yuji while they're very similar
in many many ways specifically
narratively because they both commence
the series scheduled to be executed and
there's a lot of similarities so this
may even explain some of our kotami's
trouble with yuji because yuta had a
very compelling story which will be
explored in the upcoming jujutsu kaisen
film and when starting the sequel series
yuji was created to fill that uta role
just with a bunch of different
circumstances and because yuta does
exist in jiu jitsu kaisen akatami
obviously couldn't just copy and paste
too much of yoota onto yuji so it does
lead to a potentially awkward situation
where we need to hit those same story
and character beats just in a slightly
different way and all of which is to say
that if you have not checked out the
jiu-jitsu kaisen prequel then absolutely
go and do it or i guess wait for the
film it's coming out soon enough either
way it's fascinating insight into what
we're reading and watching today as fuji
though let's get etymological with fun
fact number three yuji's name was
designed by akitami to sound as plain
normal and realistic as possible which
might be difficult for english-speaking
audiences to comprehend because every
japanese name sounds totally sugoi des
and magical to us so when their
equivalent of a john smith comes around
we're just sitting here going oh my god
that is the greatest and most unique
name ever so there's some insight into
what yuji itadore is meant to sound like
but we also know where alkatami sourced
these elements the yuji park comes from
one of akutami's old classmates and it
is written with the kanji u which is red
is slow and relaxing as well as g which
means caring for others meanwhile his
surname itadore comes directly from the
itadore plant which has often been used
as a herbal remedy so very appropriate
for someone like yuji whose aspirations
in life are to save others however the
itadore kanji combination has a very
cool and rare reading as well because
the first character eta is more commonly
read as torah which means tiger thus
giving us some decent insight into why
he was nicknamed the tiger of west
junior high but all in all even with the
appropriate subtle meanings yuji itadori
is designed to be a fairly plain and
unassuming name for someone less plain
and not at all unassuming let's now talk
about jennifer lawrence yugi famously
states that his preferred type of woman
in the series are those who are tall and
have big butts some unlike for example
jennifer lawrence although in the
jujitsukai sin fanbook this is even
taken a step further by having yuji's
type listed as simply jennifer lawrence
but while yuji's obsession here may be a
mystery in the series akatami has
revealed where all of this began and
apparently it was when yuji watched the
film's silver linings playbook for which
jennifer lawrence received an academy
award for best actress and ever since
then eugene has been something of a big
fan of her to say the least although the
designation of his type has led to a
fair bit of fun in the jujitsu kaisen
fanbase and in fact yuji's english
dubbed voice actor even comedically
redid the famous line but substituting
in megan the stallion thus leading to
many a megan meme but while his
preference in women may be very very
clear yuji's taste in food is anything
but his favorite food has been
identified as quote unquote rice bowl
with food on top so food with more food
and his least favorite food has been
registered as none so this man will
quite literally eat anything i suppose
which you know it actually makes a lot
of sense hence why he is so eager to
devour all of those tasty tasty sukuna
fingies it is a bit unusual for a shonen
protagonist though because even the big
trophy eaters usually have something
that puts them off like for luffy that's
cherry pie finato that's fresh
vegetables but for yuji nothing is off
the table which means that he really
does put the eat in itadore oh and also
it leads nicely into our next fun fact
because gege akitami was posed the
question of what would happen if fuji
consumed one of the death paintings
which just as a tldr recap they are
cursed whom existences that can evolve
into half human half ghost spirits when
implanted into a human vessel however
that idea becomes a bit tricky when it
comes to yuji because he already shares
his fleshy vessel with the king of
curses ryo min sukuna so while this is
definitely a more academic exercise the
question of what would happen if fuji
consumed to death painting does still
exist especially considering how eager
he seems to be to consume anything and
everything and according to akhitami
should this event occur then the death
painting existence would simply be
destroyed by sukuna however another
scenario was given to us as well which
is what would happen if uga to death
painting prior to consuming sukina's
finger and this is very interesting
because apparently the death painting
would not be able to evolve itself into
a hybrid with yuji's body and instead it
would be consumed and yuji would inherit
its cursed energy so either way it's
pretty bad outcome for the hypothetical
painting in question although it does
further reinforce yuju's absurd ability
to curses and according to fun fact
number seven yuji may also have some
other useful natural resistances because
apparently his body fat percentage is
within single digit numbers now this is
particularly intriguing because the
average male body fat percentage would
be between 18 to 24 and we don't even
reach the single digit numbers until we
hit the realm of athletes who average
between six to 13 so yuji's general
fitness is certainly on par with the
greatest of physical specimens that this
world has to offer despite the fact that
he will as established eat pretty much
anything it's quite envious really
because yuji doesn't seem to pay too
much attention to any kind of dieting he
just eats what he wants in reasonable
portions i suppose and is granted the
form of an adonis as a reward for his
doing nothing however there may also be
a logical in-world explanation for this
due to the concept of heavenly
restrictions previous restriction users
that we've seen such as maki and
tojizenin have had documented cases of
physical strength being heavily buffed
in exchange for less or even no control
of cursed energy and yuji could be in a
very similar situation because right now
i see no other explanation for his
insane abilities but particularly his
power to maintain single-digit body fat
with his uh whatever his lifestyle is
but as part of this lifestyle yuji has
also been documented as being the best
cook amongst the first year to do to
students although i'm not quite sure how
much that means because there's only
three of them and the other two happen
to be megami fushiguru and
noborakugisaki two characters who i
would never think to award praise in the
culinary field but i suppose it does
make sense yuji does have the shonen
protagonist syndrome whereby his parents
were never around and even though he was
raised by his grandfather that would
quickly have turned into eugene needing
to learn quite a few basics about life
just in order to help out which of
course includes cooking and just in case
you were curious when it comes to the
second best cook amongst the first year
students akutami claims that it's a bit
of a sad tie neither fushiguru nor
kugisaki have any skill relevant enough
to be separated from one another so
all hail yuji i guess and speaking of
hailing yuji we should all take a moment
to recognize that he is currently one of
the dual world record holders for the
most consecutive number of black flash
attacks performed which is pretty
astounding for someone who had only been
using cursed energy for what a handful
of months before performing this feat
still the explanation for that is pretty
simple according to fellow world record
holder ken to anonymity who states that
after the first black flash the
performer enters the zone and thus
making subsequent black flashes
theoretically easier to produce rather
than pulling one out of nowhere like the
initial instance but today yugi and
nanami have performed the technique four
times in a row each and this record does
get a little bit confusing because a lot
of fans forget that it was talking about
performing the attack consecutively
which yuji did four times against hanami
however he did also perform a fifth or i
guess first black flash earlier on in
the fight which often leads people to
believe that he actually broke the
record sadly however that first black
flash is invalid because there were many
many other attacks that came in between
that and the consecutive four but still
yuji the dude performed five black
flashes in a single day and that feels
pretty damn impressive but quite
possibly the most intriguing and also
kind of concerning fact about yuji is
that gege akutami still has not decided
what his ultimate fate will be at this
point in the judicial manga we are
stated to be about halfway through and
that akutami has quite a clear road map
to the end of the series for example
characters like fushiguro have their
story set in stone but that is not the
case for yuji and this may once again
have to do with the difficulties akitami
has with writing the character but i
find it quite interesting that there is
a legitimate question mark as to his
ultimate fate because in my mind there
are only two basic options one being
that yuji lives and the other being that
yuji dies and i don't want to make
myself sound too bloodthirsty here but i
am very much in the camp of the latter i
very much liked the idea that jujutsu
kaisen was set up to arrive at the
inevitable conclusion of yuji's death
whether that be via execution
sacrificing himself to reward asukana or
even potentially another way it doesn't
matter so long as it satisfies his
grandfather's last words of making sure
not to die alone and i think that a
series like jujutsu kaisen could
actually pull off killing its
protagonist in a way that many many
others could not akutami has never been
shy of exploring dark not even dark but
just like somber and depressing ideas in
the series stuff that really hits you in
the emotional testicles and at this
point i feel like yuji living and having
a happy ending would kind of betray
everything that we've been working up
towards until now however with that said
i am not a world class manga author i am
a random australian dude guy and i very
much trust akutami's intuition when it
comes to storytelling thinking about it
i have very few criticisms of jujutsukai
sin in that regard it's almost
unbelievable really because i tend to
rip other series apart like brittle
paper but kaisen is it's just really
solid so if akatami has an ending in
mind where yuji does live then yeah
maybe that's the right way to go i just
can't quite see it myself at the moment
and i guess to be fair even akatami
themselves is struggling with landing on
that final choice so for an easy choice
to make here's another video to watch i
promise it'll be great fun just like
this one so i look forward to seeing you
there